i'm
23 years old and sometimes i wonder if
life was wasted on me
definitely want to begin and i asked the
russo brothers this question too so tom
no pressure here but
you know there's a bit of a bromance
that you guys have now over the course
of several films
want to take stock at what that bromance
level is right now if level one
is we're friends and level 10 is we're
lifelong collaborators
where are we at right now what level of
bromance
probably about 11. i think
i think i will continue to work with the
russos for as long as they'll have me
i have never worked with people where
we've had so much fun on screen and off
screen
and they're so kind and welcoming to new
people to people they've worked with in
the past
they're both immensely talented and uh
and i would jump at any opportunity to
work with the both of them again
ciara you know knowing that your co-star
and the directors have this sort of
uh relationship that's gone on for
several films is that
sort of more comforting you know that
familiarity coming into a situation like
that
for you um i found it intimidating
oh yeah i found it so scary because i'm
like oh [ __ ]
like that sorry i'm sorry i was like
they already know each other they're
friends now i gotta come in here and
like
try but no they were so
they were so welcoming and so warm and
it was the opposite of all of my
anxiety spirals and fears and it really
was a wonderful experience
that's awesome you know for the both of
you and i'll begin with you ciara
you have to play characters at different
eras in their lives
uh which has got to be really
challenging
uh for for you as performers what was
the most rewarding error
of this person's life that you played um
and
was it also the most challenging it
actually was for me the most rewarding
era or chapter of this story was dope
life because i feel like we had to go to
some
really really extreme places some really
dark places mentally to to tell the
story
um in the best way possible and so when
you
sort of shred yourself in that way and
give so much of yourself to the
character
you want it to pay off and i do feel
really proud of the work that we did in
this movie tom i mean is absolutely
exceptional and
you know his passion and care and
strength is is
so clear in this as well what about for
utah
it's an interesting question i think if
you look back at
the workload it would have to be dope
life but i think
the stuff that we did at the beginning
of the film that sets up the love story
and sets up this character who is very
very capable of making a poor decision
for me i think it's some of my best work
because
it had to be very nuanced it had to be
very subtle we didn't want to make it
obvious that this kid was on a path
um that not many people would would
survive on
so for me i actually found that portion
of the film much
more difficult to to to bring to life
uh especially coming off of the back of
doing dope life where
we were on set and we were pushing
ourselves so much and crying and
screaming and vomiting to all of a
sudden just doing a scene about two
people falling in love
i i i felt really stressed because i was
like i'm not working as hard
so i can't be doing as good a job so
getting over that insecurity that
you know being exhausted doesn't equate
to being a good actor
so yeah so i found that section very
rewarding when i watched it back
you know i think it's interesting a lot
of people are gonna watch this film you
know
tom they're gonna be spider-man fans or
marvel fans and they're gonna come to
this film
because of that you know and i think
there are so many things that
people can take away from this film you
know for me the ptsd parts of this
really resonated i have family that went
through the military and had
had to deal with some of that and so you
know what do you hope people that are
coming in for those reasons
take away from this film i hope that
they realize that they're not alone
um i hope this film can help them convey
to people that don't understand their
struggles
sierra has been saying in interviews
that the battle of ptsd and
substance abuse is one that's mostly
fought in the shadows by yourself
so i hope this film can really help
people feel more comfortable about
expressing their feelings and sharing
what they're going through and also
making people
like myself who didn't know much about
this problem more sympathetic
and and more open-minded to to the awful
problem that is substance abuse and ptsd
when you make a movie like this what you
really hope people take away from it
is a sense of connection and i hope that
we are able to further the conversation
that's been started from
you know activists and films before us
just to create a new space for us to
speak about it with our family members
and our loved ones and
educate ourselves on the pain that
people go through and
and what's currently available to people
battling addiction especially
our veterans coming home from war and
hopefully we can
encourage some growth in those areas of
our lives as well
you know the model of movie making is
rapidly
evolving this film is going to be in
theaters it's also going to be available
to watch at home
you know moving forward with the
projects that you both decide to choose
do you how much is that a factor like
when you decide to do a role
about whether it's going to premiere on
tv first or if it's going to be in
theaters first
how important has that decision now
become in your lives
for me personally when i'm thinking
about which project i want to do
next it very rarely comes down to like
where is this going to end up and is
more so
what story are we telling how are we
telling it and who am i who am i telling
it with you know ultimately i want to be
working on projects that
continue to spark that passion inside of
me and in the people that i'm making the
movie with
because i think that's when you really
get that magic i think uh you know the
industry is definitely changing
streaming services are becoming more
prominent i think you have to remind
yourself that no matter where the film
starts it always ends up on telly every
film
has a has a life on television so you're
just kind of skipping a few steps
i think there are certain films that
weren't being shown on the big screen
and certain films that it's not
necessary you know i do think that
cinema is best experienced in a big seat
with a big screen and a box of popcorn
but um you know the industry is changing
and we're all gonna have to figure out
how to adapt to it
but uh but no i don't think uh where the
film
is being shown really has an effect on
my decision as to whether i'll make it
or not
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
let me just dive right in my first
question you know uh
you direct the last movie that you
co-direct together is
the highest grossing movie of all time
so uh i imagine
when you're choosing a follow-up film to
direct together
um the sky's the limit really so uh
two-part question but did you feel
pressure in in selecting
what that project was going to be and
then why did it become
cherry one we didn't feel any pressure
and i think
part of what helped us be successful in
that run we had with marvel was
closing off the outside world a bit you
know the noise from the outside world
um uh and just making choices that made
us creatively satisfied
and we made movies that we wanted to see
it's good that there's two of us that
really helps
us ground each other and um and uh
and have a dialogue that uh that sort of
excludes
external noise um we picked this because
um the the opioid crisis has touched us
deeply
very personally um this book is about
our hometown written by nico walker who
grew up in our hometown of the same
neighborhoods we grew up in
he and i worked at the same restaurant
about 10 years apart from each other
so and it really speaks to the
existential crisis that a lot of that
city and
and parts of the industrial midwest find
themselves in and why
opioids have taken such hold there we
have friends and family who are
struggling with
their sobriety others who have died from
addiction so it just was a very personal
very important issue for us you know i
do want to mention
you do have a bit of a bromance going
with tom holland uh
this is several films you've worked on
now with him uh if we were to take stock
of that bromance level right now
level one being like we're just friends
level 10 being like this is a lifelong
collaborator where would you feel like
your bromance level with mr holland is
at this point in time
probably 11. yeah so
we uh yeah no we we adore tom i mean he
is
uh among the most talented people we've
ever encountered
he's also one of the most genuine
and hardworking and kind people we've
ever encountered so yeah i mean we
we we can't do enough with tom you know
um i'm sure we'll be working with him
throughout our careers
and look at he was incredibly important
to this movie i mean this was a hard
move
this is a hard movie you know it's about
difficult things and tom there's
you know there's not a lot of actors
that are as charismatic
and and fun to watch as tom and it's
like if you're going to go on a journey
if you're going to go on a difficult
journey
you want to you want him to be your your
guide
and um he you know what he brought this
to this movie we can't overstate
and uh we were just we're really
grateful for our collaboration with him
you know the the future of the movie
landscape is really interesting right
now
you know uh this film in particular it's
going to be in theaters for a couple of
weeks and then it's going to be
available to watch at home
uh lots of windows are changing and
whatnot uh
while we've been through this pandemic
and as you move forward do you think
about these kinds of things and the
kinds of projects that you're taking on
considering that
the way people uh consume content
is just evolving at a rapid pace right
now 100
i mean i think that there's incredible
value in what's happening i mean i think
we really have to understand like how
it's opening things up and there was a
period there was very anemic
in in theatrical business where you know
movies like this
just just weren't you weren't being seen
because people didn't you know there's a
barrier of entry there they got to pay
twenty dollars to go the theater fifty
dollars for the babysitter
a hundred dollars for dinner it's a big
experience it's a big ask of them
here's the other thing that's really
important too there's a there's an
enormous
international audience uh um that is of
a different
socio-economic status than most
americans where
the theater is something that is not
attainable
for them and you know having digital
distribution
allows them to view stories uh a
lower barrier of entry for them and uh
that's incredibly important that's about
the democratization
of storytelling i also think that you
know
theatrical space was was uh was a
risk-averse space
and it uh and diversity was not
priority in theatrical uh uh
movies for years and i think if you you
know look at the old guard and
you know what's happening now in in the
digital space is that
one there's more content uh you know uh
two
there's a priority now for diversity and
three
it's um you know it it it it affords
it affords greater opportunity i think
for riskier content
than theatrical does i think you'll see
moving forward theatrical is going to be
almost exclusively eventized content i
agree
uh you know speaking of event size
content i'm sure that you have
i'm sure everybody's in your ear about
returning at some point to a superhero
movie universe
my question about that would be would
you ever consider doing what your buddy
james gunn did
go do a big dc blockbuster look joe and
i love
uh filmmaking on every scale you know
we've made
movies for as little money as you could
possibly make movies for we've made
movies for as much money as you possibly
make movies for
and we love everything in between i mean
we will
we will someday for sure do do a movie
in that genre again probably in the not
too distant future
who it's with and you know we're not
we're not uh able to say at this point
but yeah we're we like challenging
ourselves we like finding new frontiers
so
uh it's it's a surprise to us where
we're going and hopefully it'll be a
surprise to audiences as well
can you look back to when you met the
one you loved the most
you remember exactly how it was
[Music]
you